Thank
[Silence]
those
matter.
was a message.
There's well known
of
the prophet
[Silence]
that in
it not
and say that
myself
don't want.
So
why he is in the lowest level of the
fire or that's where he belongs.
Now remember the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam interceded on his behalf made
dua to Allah and Allah relieved him of
much of that
however that's his rightful place right
next to the hypocrites.
Why? because of this issue of
mud
this compromise
in the
tenants of Islamahill.
This playing around with the truth as if
it belongs to you or me.
This is one of the greatest
sins a person can commit.
Not just against Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala or his own soul but also against
the integrity of human existence.
Because if we as human beings cannot
agree on what is right and wrong, what
is the point of our existence even?
And so this is an example of al- mudah
Abu Talib he wants to become Muslim but
he compromised that why did he
compromise it to appease
the popular to appease
the rest of the prophet's antagonist.
This is called mudahana
right
and there are many examples of this
mudahana
throughout the time in Mecca and
throughout the time in medina.
We mentioned that we would take two
examples of mud
from
and two examples of
al- mud.
Another example of al- mud
is that
they came to the prophet sallall.ai
with an offer. They said look
don't
insult our gods. What's meant by
insulting here? Insulting meaning
invalidating their authority
doesn't mean using profanity. That's not
what the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam did per se. What's meant by
insulting here
in the Arabic language?
Insulting meaning undermining our
gods is probably better than insult.
Undermining our gods. Don't in undermine
our idols. All right? Just don't speak
about them. Just don't say anything bad
about them. And if you don't say
anything bad about them, we won't say
anything bad about you and we won't do
anything and we will let you do this and
that. We will leave your religion alone
and not speak bad about it if you just
not invalidate and undermine
our religion and our and our idols.
However, this is a type of compromise
because that means that parts of the
Quran cannot be recited. They cannot be
publicly
recited
because the Quran in its most essential
verses
is
very clear in its undermining of
idolatry and specifically even by name
the idols of the mushri. Right.
Just don't recite that anymore. Not
publicly in your house. Yeah. Go recite
it to yourself, but don't tell that to
anyone. Don't recite it anymore.
No, don't say that publicly. Just just
don't say it publicly. All right? Don't
say that the worship of these idols is
wrong. Just keep that to yourself
and we will allow you this and that.
This is a type of compromise that Allah
prohibited him from.
Subhanahu wa ta'ala. And he said in no
uncertain terms, he sent down the verses
There's no
misconception.
There's no maybe it meant it is a
negative term,
right?
And so the only way that Islam can be
prominent enough in the minds of its
followers and also in the minds of those
who it is calling is if its opposite is
disparaged. Correct? I mean these things
come together. Aren't they two sides to
to the same coin? Isn't it that in order
for us to be Muslim, we have to be
disbelievers in all that opposes Islam?
Doesn't Allah say,
"So that means that in order to become
Muslim, you have to be a disbeliever in
all other." Correct?
This is a necessary component to the
propagation of Islam.
Which is why the scholars tell us
that is it obligatory for a person who
lives
as a minority amongst the majority of
non-Muslims? Is it obligatory upon that
person to make hijra? It's a well-known
issue that the scholars have discussed.
And the majority opinion is
that a person may live
as a minority amongst the majority of
non-Muslims
under the condition
that he is able to
he is able to publicly
worship Allah that he is able to be
public in his worship of Allah he is
able to be public as a Muslim he doesn't
have to hide his Islam
but this issue of public I mean what is
its h how do we define that how do we
quantify that the scholars say
Islam
that a person is is able to not only
praise Islam but dispraise all other
religions.
That a person is able to praise Allah
and dispraise
other gods aside or other deities
that are worshiped aside from Allah.
Subhanahu wa ta'ala. Why? Because this
is part of
this is part of
Allah says what is a if a person is
whispering is that considered
is that a person is able to be public
that a person is able to say I am
Muslim.
And for this reason, when Islam became
something that was no longer
a person was no longer able to be
publicly Muslim in Mecca, that's when
Allah commanded alhra.
That's when alh took place. But did they
have to make hij from Ethiopia to
Medina? No. Why? Because they were able
to be public with their Islam.
And this is not to say that a person is
standoffish or that a person is
antagonizing
of people of other religions. That's not
the point here. It's not a point of
being antagonistic.
Right? If you insult someone, they're
going to have a bad reaction. That is
human nature. Right? What's meant here
is that in a general sense, a person is
able to say
and is able to
is able to quantify that and detail
that without fear of repression or fear
of exile or fear of being
ostracized in his community.
And so these are examples of tomorrow
inshallah we'll take examples of what
because
not even 1% is acceptable
in a Muslim
but al
100% is expected from a Muslim.
They are stark opposites but in spite of
that they are commonly confused. So we
will discuss tomorrow inshallah
[Silence]
Subhan Allah.
Sir, Mr.